we're here on today's wrap-up show with
the very funny Desi liic uh you guys
know her as a correspondent on The Daily
Show uh you're going to be back on The
Daily Show right I am yes that's
happening next week next week
correspondent takeover very excited I am
I am I can't believe they're letting me
back there again I I took one crack at
it in April and for some crazy reason
they let me do it again what's it like
when you are finally given the
opportunity to sit in the chair and ride
out as the host oh my God I was first of
all I walked into that job eight years
ago when Trevor started I I watched and
all through my 20s through the John
years I worshiped that show I auditioned
for the show to be a correspondent three
times over the years um so I never
thought ever I'd get a chance to sit at
the desk and when I did I was so nervous
I was thrilled and of course I like put
my hand up because you have to when when
an opportunity like that opens up but I
was like I don't know if I can do this I
was anxious for months leading into it
and I sat down on my first day and I
don't know if you know this but in late
night we do use teleprompters so we use
a prompter and I sit down and our stage
manager points to me and I say welcome
to the Daily Show I'm Desi liic and I'm
looking in the prompter and it's
completely reversed the prompter is like
a mirror image and I I just went with it
and then and then went and work we're
going to have to do that again cuz the
prompter is
reversed literally the worst thing that
could have possibly happened happened on
day one yeah and we some the audience
was with me they clapped and we moved on
and from that point on I just like
settled in I thought if I can get
through that I can get through anything
sometimes it's those big like flubs that
give you an opportunity to relax and
collect yourself faster than you would
if it didn't happen yeah cuz you're just
like waiting for that to happen and once
it happens you can just move through it
yeah
m